so that actually might person and even
worse than a 911 people can work from
home successfully and business can still
keep running efficiently I've had to
adapt in that way I hope this just goes
away we can actually have a more
flexible and slightly more freer life I
think it's actually better for people's
mental health I don't want to be
permanently stationed at home there
would be there unfortunate
[Music]
that's better in the kitchen better
myself we're engineers we work in the
aviation industry and as you can imagine
in the industries living their worst
times ever even worse than 9/11 for us
on top of all the stress that this
pandemic has has brought to everybody's
life it's it's another another you know
piece of stress and concern just for my
own good our business is a coffee bar in
Budapest and that's been forced to close
so it has hugely affected us let's talk
a little bit about a work so I was I
able to work from home or am i yes I
think I am however this little guy here
who is keeping me super super active I'm
hardly able to work anyhow so that's
actually my personal change - yeah to
work at all I miss interaction so much I
need to interact with other people I
need to go to work that is basically the
only source of social life I have and I
can't do that at the moment get in the
zone and what I do to be very mentally
taxing well with homeschooling and you
know Alexandre having no patience the
homeschool and monitored you that is the
biggest effect that a lot of last few
weeks
Wow I feel like these guys are all
counseling no no no no this no really
yeah
Banyan Banyan no come on I'm not that
bad
Banyan I would drive the baby's happy
it's been an interesting it was tough
especially at first I think we're
getting used to it and particularly
since we have a small baby she's about
to turn six months the other day I was
in a meeting and you could hear some
other frozen soundtrack in the
background right and people were like
singing along and so it's just different
it's just different dynamics I guess
technology to do something that I had
heard on the phone that standing
medicine and it's not the same as an
in-person concert but it is really
useful for screening patients seeing
whose urgent who really needs to come in
immediately also reassuring the patients
and just coming them down minor ailments
can be tackled
so video consult is I think something
that is going to state this is where we
work we live really close to to the
facilities of course this is a currently
closed
[Music]
working from home like I don't know it
seems like the more I spend time money
the more I like it it has some
challenges but I'm I'm thinking you may
be after this is all over I don't know
if we're gonna be thinking about working
from home a little more I guess we'll
we'll see I hope that the you know
positive outcome might be that in the
years time or two years time when all of
this hopefully is resolved we will
realize that spending more time with our
families and not being sort of stuck in
an office from 9:00 to 5:00 and
commuting and all of this I hope that we
will take that with us that we can
actually have a more flexible and
slightly more freer life that'll be
great
I feel like the way that we have been
working should have serious improvements
for our work-life balance I think more
bosses may be inclined to let people
work from home from time to time and
hopefully there is a little bit more
flex about flexibility from working from
the office and working from home one
thing we did learn I think with lockdown
lasting for over a month is that you
know people can work from home
successfully and business can still keep
running efficiently so perhaps in the
future they may incorporate more of that
into the sort of normal routine of work
and give people more flexibility I think
it's actually better for people's mental
health so I think they that may change
long-term I think we've gotten so used
to having all this extra time that when
it goes away we may struggle a little
bit I have been working from home this
whole time and it's been a blast I mean
I've been so much more productive than
when I was actually at work and while at
home I get to basically work all the
time and I've pulled a couple of
all-nighters
before I would I would ride my music I
would record it in a studio and then I'd
do shows and I would meet people to plan
these shows and I would go to the to
media houses to promote my shows and
then we would meet with people in a
venue and we would all have fun and
enjoy good music but now I have if I do
a live show it has to be right here in
my room I have to be like myself just
play some pre-made instrumentals of my
music and perform live I have a support
like I have my own spot I need to meet
more people I need to talk about space
and astronomy basically I've been so
happy to you land such a work because
I'm a huge spaceman and the moment I I
can't have any any benefits from it like
I love to meet up with scientists I love
these people I don't want to be
permanently stationed at home definitely
not that there would be very unfortunate
I just hope he doesn't go on for long
again like I hope this just goes away
because I am me singing and dancing with
people
because we a while
[Music]
you